hi my name is Geeta and I work as a
software engineer for the design system
team at sync for the one who don't know
think it's a platform for professional
networking and today I will be talking
about functional programming so first of
all I would like to share with you why I
decided to learn functional programming
I have studied computer science where I
learned Java and a little bit JavaScript
and objective oriented programming
paradigm and it was fine back then but
when I started to work in real
application that solve business problems
I barely see the same techniques I
learned back at university also I don't
know for you guys but for me debugging
code in JavaScript it's very hard so
today we live in a world where if you
want to learn new skills it's very easy
you don't need to wait for universities
and all those long processes you just
start right away
pick your computer and then start
reading about what you want to learn and
here I would like to point out something
that this way of learning it is cool but
has a side effect in it sometimes I
believe developers are very creative
human being but sometimes they create
some stereotypes like half PHP it's a
lazy language and JavaScript has heart
magic and those stereotypes are fine for
people who are very experienced but for
me as a junior who just started to code
it is very hard to understand what do
they mean and all those why I can find
an answer so that's was the reason that
I started to learn functional
programming because I thought it is cool
and first I started with to answer the
question what is functional program
actually I find it very hard to give a
definition like what is functional
programming the one I read on the
internet it's kind of boring and hard to
memorize so I decided to tell you first
the characteristics and let's see if I
will manage to give you a summarize what
I understand functional programming is
so functional programming it is a
programming paradigm let me explain to
you what I understand and I think of a
paradigm for me a paradigm it is kind of
a world view a way how we look at the
world in terms of how the world is
composed to like what elements and how
does elements interact with each other
so if we say what is functional
programming I would say it's a code
style like we look how those what
elements it contains and Hamas and and
them interact with each other so to
explain this I will try to talk about
other programming paradigms like
imperative codes so an imperative code
we write codes out of commands like
because we instruct the code line by
line like now do this and then do that
and after that do that and after do that
and as we see time here is an important
concept in imperative programming and
with that comes an idea of values
changing over the time which is called
state another characteristic of function
of imperative programming it is that for
the same input we don't always get the
same output from the other side that
this object oriented programming which
says that imperative programming it's
cool but what if our programs get
complicated and the valve manage that
state in those days are changing over
the time it is very hard so what if we
pack those data in some little units
call them object and the way how they
talk and interact or each other each
byte is it is by standing mesh
back and forth which is essentially what
we do when we call the methods and
objects one object method called the
method of another object the opposite of
imperative programming it is declarative
programming if imperative programming
was the program growth out of comments
inverting declarative programming it is
built out of expression so it's like
that's what I want I don't care how you
deliver it to me but that's what I want
so what fight what is functional
programming then so a functional
programming it is a paradigm where we
express everything with functions and
the way how they lament interact with
each other is by giving input and
transferring them into an output and how
we do that it is by using pure functions
what is a pure function a pure function
it is a function that for the same input
gets always the same output without side
effects let me explain this also
functional programming I would say it's
kind of a sub paradigm of declarative
programming so I would explain this with
an example
let's say we have a function which takes
as argument an array and you return a
new function with the double values of
the old array the code like looks like
this in declarative style which is
basically functional programming if we
want to do the to solve the same problem
in imperative code we have to do we have
to declare function which is called Dabu
age and then takes an array we have to
initialize a new array and then with the
help of a for loop we push the other
values and as you see the code this line
by line and also we use those old
methods or methyls I you I learned in
the data structure subject like four and
four and this is the good thing about
functional programming we will never
have to write a for loop or a push I
have never seen this at least and my job
actually when I think of an application
usually I have in mind like without
considering the UI part I have in mind a
list of data that we have to render in
the screen and those data can be mutable
and immutable immutable data can change
after the creation and immutable data
cannot change after the creation let me
explain this let's say we have an object
called a and it has a property fo and
which has a value bar and then we assign
the we have a new variable a which we
assign it to B and then once we want to
portion your value to the V and if we
console.log V we will see that a and V
are equal because we are not doing
anything else we assign those objects to
H they assigned to the same place so how
can we avoid those kind of mutations and
the way how I know how to do this is by
object freezing a frozen object is an
object that can no longer be changed
after creation which means we cannot
longer add new values to it but we can
no longer extract values from it also we
can do this with programmer discipline
so we use functions like the map
function or like a sine function like we
find the object to a new one and then we
added the new one but not the old one
and also there is Concord and filter but
we never have to use those old methods
we learned in the data structure like
Porsche and top and other things one of
the nice features that I love about
functional programming is high order
function a high order function it is the
function that accepts a function as an
argument or returns a new function I
think high order function at first seems
a bit scary but it's not I think it's
very helpful when our application it
gets really complicated so and we repeat
ourselves again and again
so I think it could make sense to have
something as a provider which fits the
need of the components under the tree
which are mostly the consumers let me
show you this with an example
let's say we have to build a counter for
making some mathematical calculations
and I have an high order function which
takes argument
another function we store a very odd
variable calm and then with the help of
the rest
operator we create a new function which
will return the result with the help of
the spread operator and if we want to
use now or if we want to make different
calculation with this we just have to
use this function by passing another
function to it which in this case we
have a function ad which has two
arguments X and epsilon and then to add
this function to the higher order wines
one of the topics that I still don't
feel comfortable talking with but I will
try to it is caring and compositions
sharing a caret function is the function
that takes multiple arguments at one
time as we have in this case we have a
function called substrate or sub which
first take a and create a new function
out of it which takes B and then return
a new function which substrat a minus B
and to use this we just pass values to
it so why is that helpful
I think one of the topics known as the
soul and the hearth of functional
programming is compositions let's say we
have two function like f which takes an
argument and must've add 2 to it and
then we have another function with this
G which takes an argument and added a
number 3 to compose those elements we
just nest those
together like we do it here we have the
Campos funk function and then we pass to
function to it and then we just mask the
F to the G in this way how we see it
here so why this carried a great so for
me carat is the great functions for
composing because they allow us to
easily convert functions with multiple
arguments in the stands of a single
function so I wish to give you a summary
why I think that functional programming
for me it is very great one week because
we can combine a lot of pure function
with each other and all this work with
function given in forget transforming
them into an output it is very helpful
for me also add avoiding shared state
immutable data and all the side effects
which help at least me a lot and
declarative approach that rather than
imperative approach I'm not a big fan of
declarative very difficult so for me it
is fine to use that one thank you
[Applause]